[Musique]
à partir du moment où le candidat alarme
à la main tout ce qui va faire entre
maintenant et la fin du quatrième
exercice est examinée est important pour
nous de savoir comment sont préparés les
chasseurs à l'acte de chasse et ensuite
voir les pistes d'amélioration aussi que
peuvent nous donner les fédérations de
chasse sur la sécurisation
cette mission je crois qu'il faut que
les chasseurs la presse comme étant jeu
mais c'est entre guillemets évidemment
on est toutes les sécurités nécessaires
mais comme une chance parce que si donc
on ne se pose pas ces questions c'est
essentiel la pression populaire qui aura
une part d'informations sûrement erroné
parce que n'aura pas c'est le travail de
la mission qu'on est en train de faire
pourrait avoir un élan de rejet total on
commence par une évaluation de
l'environnement à 360 degrés même si
c'est un poste qu'on occupe tous les
dimanches on doit vérifier qu autour de
soi rien n'a changé ce petit tour
d'horizon nous a permis de voir qu'on
avait deux voisins et on va s'assurer
qu'ils nous ont vu aussi ses deux
voisins on va les protéger
grâce aux fameuses angle de 30 degrés
donc 5 pas vers le voisin trois pas vers
la direction de tir et pareil pour le
deuxième voisin nos voisins sont
protégés notre chasseur revient à son
poste
et à ce moment là c'est à lui d'informer
l'inspecteur que je viens d'entendre le
signal de début de battues
à ce moment là seulement il a le droit
de s'occuper de sa carabine
un accident est un accident de trop et
on fera jamais jamais assez pour que ça
n'arrive pas donc remettre un accent là
dessus l'ensemble de la communauté des
chasseurs ça me paraît une excellente
chose et on a encore des choses à
améliorer faut pas croire que tout a été
fait je suis tout à fait optimiste sur
le fait qu'on perd encore faire beaucoup
beaucoup de choses ce qui était
intéressant c'est à la fois le sérieux à
la fois la façon assez responsables dont
les formateurs se focalise
essentiellement et notamment dans les
pays dans les apprentissages techniques
à la sécurité en fait du tir du tireur
du chasseur de ceux qui sont autour et
je pense qu'il y a ici dans cette
fédération et dans ce type de formation
des idées à faire à faire émerger et à
diffuser sur l'ensemble du territoire